alma and blanca are playing a game where
they roll a six-sided pair of dice and
try to predict the outcomes
blanca thinks that the probability of
rolling a one and a five probability of
rolling a one and a five is greater than
the probability of rolling a 1 or a 5.
alma disagrees she thinks the
probability of rolling a 1 or a 5 is
greater
based on the sample space of possible
outcomes listed below who is correct
alma or blanca
well we could just look straight at the
sample space and see how many of these
outcomes satisfy
each of these each of these situations
so the probability of rolling a one and
a five so the probability
of rolling a one
and a five
well look from this from this grid here
we see that there are 36 equally likely
outcomes
and how many of them involve rolling a
one and a five so this is a one
and a five is this one that's one and a
five and you also have you also have a
one and a five
right over here there's exactly two out
of these 36 equally likely outcomes that
involve a one and a five so there is a
one
over eighteen chance of this happening
or you could say the probability is one
eighteenth
now what's the probability of rolling a
one or a five
well a one or a five so probability of
one
or
a five
well all of these involve all of these
over here involve a one my pen
it's digital pen but it looks like it's
running out of ink
those all involve a one and all of these
involve a five
all of these involve a five right over
here
all over these involve a 5.
those involve a 5. and actually actually
we're not done yet all we have all of
these involving a 1 right over here
and you have all of these involving a
five this was one for the first die five
for the first eye these are one for the
second die
five for the second die
so how many total outcomes are there
well it's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20.
so it's 20
out of the 36 equally likely outcomes or
if we divide both the numerator and the
divide the denominator by 4 we get 5
over 9. 5 9 of the equally likely
outcomes involve a one or five
so clearly five ninths is larger than
one eighteen five ninths the same thing
as ten
ten eighteens so the probability of a
one or a five is greater so alma was
right alma thinks that the probability
of rolling a one or a five is greater so
who is who is correct alma alma is
correct
now it was good to go through this
exercise of identifying the subset of
our sample space that meets each of
these situations but you could have just
thought about it as well even if you
didn't have the sample space in front of
you what blanca was saying the
probability of a one and a five you have
to have a one and a five that's a much
more stringent constraint than a one or
a five a one or a five is going to
include many many more things it's gonna
include a two and a one a three and a
one it's gonna include a five and a
three not just a five and a one so just
even without even looking at this
without actually even having to
calculate these probabilities you could
have said look what alma is saying has a
higher probability it makes sense
because she's placing a much looser
constraint a one or a five not one and a
five